nadège le disait vous vous êtes au
rassemblement se rappelle de fleurant
philippot madej bon vous respecte son
appel a été entendu aujourd'hui
[Musique]
absolument à magna puisque entendu un
puisqu'ils sont plusieurs dizaines de
les deux manifestants peut-être même
beaucoup plus à avoir répondu à son
appel alors 5e samedi de mobilisation
nationale consécutifs prendre neuvième
semaine de mobilisation ici pour les
manifestants et les à l'appel un du
groupe les tic les patriotes alors ces
manifestants présents ici ils
manifestent contre le pass sanitaire s
est généralisée depuis quelques jours à
d'autres lieux du quotidien il va
falloir depuis cinq jours maintenant et
représentait un pas sanitaires pour
aller dans les bars les restaurants à
elle et cafés ou dans les transports de
longue distance ou encore dans les
hôpitaux en sauf urgence impasse
sanitaire que ces manifestants présents
ici est bien qualifié de discriminatoire
et or se fait attendre sur eux à leur
liberté individuelle chocolat
pour contester le pass sanitaire qui est
moi aucune raison d'être parce que pour
moi il ya deux solutions soit d'un point
de vue sanitaire
la vaccination est nécessaire dans ce
cas là on le rend obligatoire soit il
n'est pas nécessaire et on n'a pas
discriminer les gens qui sont au maxi
naissant que moi tout simplement dû à la
liberté je trouve que chacun doit avoir
une liberté de choix à mon âge je suis
vacciné mais je trouve scandaleux qu'on
empêche des restaurants des bars il faut
être fou coin dans le même temps où je
viens d'arriver en métro je suis désolé
dans le métro on est comme dans des des
sardines dans le métro on se fiche du
monde ce gouvernement est un
gouvernement je vais pas dire
autoritaire mais abusivement totalitaire
on ne peut plus le supporter c'est
insupportable les opposants qui
manifestent aux cris de liberté de la
résistance est en moi à florian
philippot le leader des patriotes et
bien si
une nouvelle manifestation réussie avec
une affluence record du jamais vu selon
lui en plein mois d'août vous propose
d'écouter le leader despatie
j'ai envie de dire on fait le débat que
macro n'a pas voulu et on fait dans la
rue puisqu'il n'a pas voulu le faire il
a été à marche forcée à l'assemblée et
au sénat en plus avec des gens qui sont
pas bien résistant dans les assemblées
là bas qui ont tendance à obéir et puis
un conseil social qui s'est prononcé à
toute vitesse qui comme d'habitude s'est
soumis mais il est où le peuple
souverain là dedans bah il est là quand
on lui prive on le prive de ses droits
il reprend ses droits naturellement il
les reprend pas les moyens qu'il a la
rue et ça fait trente neuf semaines
consécutives les patriotes qu'on y est
trente neuf semaines consécutives et
partout en france et elle est par
ailleurs bas par les boycotts du pas
saint ythaire dès qu'on peut par la
valorisation des lieux de liberté par
les grèves j'ai vu les pompiers j'ai eu
des liens collectifs de soignants par le
blocage des routiers qui vont entrer
dans la danse voilà c'est ça un pays qui
se réveille et on va continuer tant
qu'on n'aura pas gagné parce qu'il faut
qu'on arrête le délire actuelle
l'entretien de la peur l'entretien de la
peur ça n'est plus supportable
et le gouvernement a de nouveau réitéré
son intention à cette semaine et bien
d'arrêter de stopper lé remboursement
des tests de dépistage test antigénique
tests pcr ce sera le courant mi octobre
ils vont donc devoir devenir payant
objectifs du gouvernement et bien
favorisé motivé es les français à se
faire vacciner un maximum alors se passe
sanitaires à il est déjà mise en place à
l'international par de nombreux autres
pays la grèce l'italie ou encore israël
mais qu'importe les manifestants ici est
présent et ont pour objectif de faire
plier le de m'enfoncer de le motiver et
bien à faire marche arrière et puis de
mettre un terme à ce passe sanitaires
ils nous disent ils nous confient qu'ils
continueront à manifester à protester
contre ce pas sanitaire le temps qu'il
faudra
merci nadège pour toutes ces précisions